you want to go there that's Miami Beach
yeah I want to go we welcome you back to
CBS mornings today marks the official
start of hurricane season in our series
protecting the planet CBS News is
partnering with the weather channel to
investigate Florida's flooded future and
why some residents there are uniquely
unprepared more than one-third of
Florida's properties are at risk of
severe flooding over the next 30 Years
now last year at least 10 billion
dollars of flood damage from Hurricane
Ian was not covered by insurance now a
combination of stronger storms fueled by
climate change a strained insurance
industry and lack of effective state
regulations has millions of low-income
residents facing a major coverage Gap so
that's not good Manuel bojorquez is in
Miami with more on that part of the
story Manny we just had Jim Cantore here
who said it only takes one storm to make
a mess in Florida they know this song
very very well
we know it all too well unfortunately
Gail good morning to you let's talk
about this Florida's insurance industry
is in crisis with seven companies
shutting down since last February this
is all happening as some people are
still cleaning up from last year's
storms and as critics say the state is
not doing enough to inform people about
their flood risks
so this is it huh yeah you're walking
into the living room 56 year old Diana
Mercado lived in her Fort Myers home for
26 years until hurricane Ian hit last
September so is this your kitchen what
was once a happy home full of family and
memories now looks more like a
construction site this was the one with
the words damage it really destroyed
everything that was here
hurricane Ian hit as a catastrophic
category 4 storm pummeling the state
with 150 mile per hour winds and rain
more than 150 people were killed and
storm damage surpassed 100 billion
dollars making it the most expensive
storm in Florida's history
Mercado was among the two and a half
million Floridians forced to evacuate
she went to stay with her daughter Sarai
Santos who lives more Inland in nearby
Lehigh Acres about 45 minutes away when
you evacuated what did you expect you
would come back home to just maybe all
the trees some trees that's what
happened in the past you never thought I
never thought even though I have the
lake in the back it has never been a
problem
mercado's home was filled with
waist-deep water I get to her house and
it's not the same house
it looked bad all I see was mud and
there were some um
lombrices
worms on in my closet everything was wet
I saw okay we lost everything all the
water kind of came from the back Mercado
had home insurance but without flood
insurance she quickly realized she could
not afford the out-of-pocket cost of
repairs which were quoted between 50 and
70 thousand dollars
Dr Rick Nabb is the former director of
the National Hurricane Center and a
tropical weather expert for The Weather
Channel it only takes a couple of inches
of water in your home to cause tens of
thousands of dollars in damage just
think what it does to the carpet if it
gets up to the level of the electrical
outlets what that does to your
electrical system mercado's home like
many other Coastal parts of the U.S is
in a FEMA flood zone residents who live
in these areas are federally required to
have flood insurance but Mercado says
she was never informed by real estate or
insurance agents that her property was
in one of those zones if they told me
you need to have it I would have gotten
but I didn't know
according to the natural resource
defense Council Florida is one of 21
states with no requirements to disclose
flood risks to home buyers sellers do
not have to say whether the property is
in a flood zone if they are required to
have flood insurance or if the home has
flooded before so home buyers in Florida
basically receive no information that
would help them avoid buying a
flood-prone property Rob Moore is a
senior policy analyst for the natural
resources defense Council it's a
particularly bad problem for lower
income individuals than many of the
major cities of the U.S those redlined
areas are the most flood-prone areas of
those cities so due to no fault of their
own we've kind of channeled black people
and lower income people into areas that
are at fairly high risk for many lower
income residents the cost of insurance
is also becoming unaffordable in Florida
the cost of flood insurance averages
nearly one thousand dollars a year
and those prices are only expected to
grow in the coming years because FEMA
recently changed the way it calculates
flood insurance prices National flood
insurance program premiums in high risk
areas could jump by thousands doesn't
seem very fair in general to put the
flood insurance burden so heavily on the
people who can least afford it the areas
that flood repetitively are often places
where people don't necessarily want to
live in
says real estate and insurance agents
need to be doing more to inform people
of their risks they should be going to
bat for you to find out the information
these are things that were taken from
the house yeah nearly eight months after
Hurricane Ian most of mercado's
salvageable belongings are still in her
daughter's garage rebuilding is slow so
you've done some of the work yourself
that is correct removing drywall and
such yes YouTube has taught me a lot
how would you describe what this
experience has been like I cannot say
that I'm homeless but I think it feels
like okay you homeless I have for
thank you
she's been great to me
she says her daughter has been her Rock
back to the issue at hand Florida
lawmakers are now considering changing
state law to require sellers to disclose
flooding but there's another issue for
homeowners some of FEMA's flood maps are
out of date the agency says that is due
to climate change and it is working to
update them Tony yeah now Florida is a
very different place weather-wise than
just when I was a kid there 30 years ago
and the insurance industry has got to
catch up with it or the legislature does
many eye-opening report thank you very
much
seems like updating those flood maps
have to be a top priority right now well
they know that today is not like the
past but they really don't know what
tomorrow is going to be like so it's
hard to predict yeah but Tony the people
that live there really my sister I have
two sisters that live there they really
love it nobody plans to move even though
they know this is an issue yeah all of
this the problem is she didn't know she
wasn't told by her real estate agent
it's still Paradise right and the taxes
are low what are you going to do about
it what am I going to do about it you're
a Florida native can I move there can I
do this